in this video we'll be talking about MHC
gene expression so MHC Gene and HLA
cluster is a very important topic in
usml step one this is a High eeld video
so MHC stands for major hist
compatibility complex and there are two
categories of MHC class one MHC which is
found in any nucleated cell and Class 2
MHC which are found in antigen
presenting cells like this dendritic
cell class one and Class 2 MHC molecule
differs in terms of their structure and
type of antigen they display on their
surface for example class 1 MHC displays
endogenous antigen or viral peptides
every nucleated cell has this class 2
MHC displays exogenous antigen that came
from outward Source let's say antigen
from a
bacteria now it's also important to note
that class 1 MHC has one long chain and
one short chain and class and and a beta
2 microG globuline is also there and in
case of Class 2 MHC there are two equal
length
chain Alpha and beta so basically these
chains are actually encoded by specific
genes so class 1 MHC genes encode these
class 1 MHC mRNA that ultimately give
rise to this part particular domain wise
structure note that beta 2 microG
globuline is not expressed by the MHC
genes in contrast the class 2 MHC is
encoded by two different uh genes one
for Alpha chains one for beta
chains now the entire MHC Gene is
present in chromosome number six and it
is known as the H cluster or human Lucy
antigen
cluster this cluster is around
4,000 uh kobas SP long and it has
different variations of Class 2 class 1
and class 3 MHC molecule it's important
to note that MHC genes are highly
polymorphic meaning there is significant
genetic diversity within this Gene in a
population so this is how the overall
cluster look like this is a
oversimplified diagram anyway so the
major uh players in class 1 MHC is a b
and c and the class 2 m is DP DM and Dr
so MHC genes are inherited as linked
genes that means these gen genes in the
chromosome are physically located quite
uh close to each other due to this
physical proximity recombination is
literally not possible the probability
is super low that is why they are uh
segregated as a unit then the question
is how does MHC diversity is achieved if
recombination is not happening and MHC
diversity is really important because in
the world there are diverse set of
antigens that need to be presented to
the immune system then how it is
possible if there is no diversity in MHC
MHC diversity exist but how does the
gene expression explain this so the
answer lies in the polymorphism MHC
genes are highly polymorphic so
polymorphism refers to existence of
multiple alic form of MH genes within a
particular population
so we have to understand this
polymorphism is a population level
concept not individual level concept and
these alic variation result due to small
genetic variation in the MHC Locus so
question is where does these genetic
variation occurs throughout the MHC
domains or any specific location is
there and the peptide sequencing shows
the variability in the residues are
specifically located in a distinct
location
so it's not
halfly located alpha 1 Alpha 2 and Alpha
3 there are specific locations which are
hot spot for
polymorphism and it has been shown from
extra crystalographic data that these
highly polymorphic regions fall in the
peptide binding groove of the MHC uh
molecules that means these changes would
determine how MHC would interact with a
anti
and that is super important in context
of immune system because pathogens are
evolving all the time they are creating
diversity so it's a constant battle with
the pathogen how our body's immune
system can also bring in diversity and
this polymorphism is one of the way by
which MHC diversity is orchestrated
another typical Factor about MHC alil is
its codominant
expression that means alil from the
mother and the father both both are
active mRNA is transcribed from the
paternal copy and the maternal copy as
well so that so the question is why
codominant expression is beneficial
because this results in the expression
of diverse array of MHC molecules on the
cell surface so generally it is another
way of increasing the diversity because
if only paternal uh versions are
expressed it might not be that diverse
so if if you have a combinatorial
expression of paternal and maternal copy
in different cell types so diversity
automatically increase the entire goal
of immune system is to create diverse
set of MHC
molecules now these MHC molecules are
important in disease context for example
these are important for autoimmune
disorders there are different alic
versions of HLA clusters let's say HLA
Class 2 MHC molecule has different
divers diverse alic forms one of them is
h dr4 h dr4 or isopor is very much
associated with the risk of developing
rheumatoid arthritis not only this
particular example there are plethora of
example which shows specific alic
variant of H Dr dqr associated with the
risk of autoimmune
disorders now apart from these disease
context MHC got its name from tissue
grafting experiments so MHC or major
hiso compatibility complex was named
because because these set of genes and
their product were involved or they
determine the compatibility of a graft
whether a graft would be rejected or
accepted that depends on these Gene
products and that's why doctors all over
the world prefer HLA typing before
tissue grafting and this ensures that
tissue graft is not rejected otherwise
there could be detrimental consequence
of the tissue graft so I hope this video
was useful and if you like this video
give it a quick thumbs up don't forget
to like share and subscribe you can
support our Channel using super than see
you in next
[Music]
video